[Music]
okay
all right let's do this i know it feels
fast but
it's nice isn't it to have a family unit
come on in to meet the boys they're
really excited to meet you
[Music]
how you feeling about school you can
meet some new friends
i know why the caged bird sings wow
that is super nasty
all right enough settle down
[Music]
hey it happens to everyone he's made us
all cry at one point or another
you should come over after school
[Music]
what is all this this is a ceremony
to celebrate you
why would you celebrate me because
you're out fourth
just in time for first period
this is all just a little crazy half the
battle of having powers is
believing you do that's why covens have
always been important
[Music]
if we can do that what else can we do
we need to put a spell on timmy we don't
want to hurt him though right
she's right the number one rule of the
craft
if a person is a danger to herself or
others
they will be bound
i'm starting to get a little worried
sorry i was just hanging out with my
friends
a lot of weirdos out here we are the
weirdos mister
[Music]
you